hi everybody that's again I'm doing the
second part of the interview with Aeneid
we did the first part was about
languages and the second time is going
to be about my images as well but we're
going to delve a little bit more into
details on how I mean it goes about
learning languages so hi I'm Ian how you
doing hey Luca I'm doing good thanks
what about yourself it's great healing
Paris this wonderful weather and I'm
very very happy that's good to hear yeah
yeah it's springtime so let's move on to
our first question that I wanted to ask
you and it's going to English yeah um
the first question is how do you how do
you choose how do you pick up languages
how do you choose a language do you do
it because you feel like a you just came
across a very interesting person or
because you read some books and you got
interested in a certain culture or in a
history of a culture of a country or
well it was compulsory for me to study
English at school so that was the first
foreign language that I started learning
and as far as other languages are
concerned you know being a native
Russian speaker you you come across
different books for example by by
Tolstoy as you know in some points in
history Russian aristocracy spoke
excellent German and excellent French
you still find lots of French or German
words in there in Russian so I kind of
had this idea that hey maybe so someday
that would it would be good to pick up
maybe French and German and well Spanish
because as you know I'm a big soccer fan
so and I also had this idea too to be
able to speak Spanish someday you know
in order to read or listen to to the
interviews with with my favorite soccer
players so it was it was more very yeah
based on partially on cultural
background and on interest so yeah
okay let's do some listen after trading
intraday this far thanks to Anna
Schwartz lon
each man of Istanbul the Venice language
on the favelas to insistence the
dissolution myopic is art work Cosima
Constitution to Iceland and is a Sufi
shrine and Metro the Commission Thomas
before Neiman's
yes iced man condemned MOTD not to
comply Titus command super ya lubber man
can i neva no sooner was the realest
sure the funk man can quasi in another
illustration account pile name or by a
man i per coulomb was student happened
yeah I'm fine law which is so Vista Hine
and mentors to Heartland Mentalist
Michelle Thomas the vendors north
he had this fit with this manner yes
Cavendish dis metal finished mayor then
interval the side had thought might be
tourists at built want yeah yes which is
your each mere machine material be
assimil Sebastian want teach yourself
who don't know condition self I want
colloquial serious s ki Fateh see a
field under yeah okay italiano Canelli
2:11 argumento good time they move
interesante diba tudo que Aquila
grammatically versus a koala e to
approach shown apotheon even from the
musculature and remodel agrammatic
action
she say a party any a la tipo de persona
Cavalli on in Ferrari
- Kelly regular subito prefer each key
in which a attacker directamente la
lingua in theory Richard you do
mr. Cooley Dola the punty would
interesante
nabela demanda commanded to giant that
is core in method or developing women to
the linguist here she transformed otto
supposed to do cozy inicio I will disown
you the the little professor for force
today they call a equity inicio cuantos
baleog Oprah's NPO once a cuddly but she
only get negative peak volleyball
wouldn't appeal to the variable is
suited to a SS value given her a molto
molto molto de Luz so modest so sure
Cody Montaner Ella like Alma or cambiado
super to tow your Miata semento Perkin
to Roberta develop resume to the
telegram Ithaca but Betty dick on every
table when you done towpath show the
lyric want to Peluso a cake windy a man
a memoir melio male intelligent Percy it
really for a super re subito
she's eventually across Virginia
coalitional you'd want me see as the
coast mug between Alaska's ice cut the
stitch takuma for oshiruko show you
Rodney
he is chili which G be a spits
animatronic yet precoded some OPA CBS if
National shatters the shelf is reg to
ask you to know whatever specific
compliment
touch the president Raney accent yeah
demoted covertly where they speak with
the chain is a co-president rainy II
intimacy
Selena
representin the Savio para is too young
to stadium as Pallavas listas utilises
vocabulary retrievers flashcard so
please Okayama noun kikuyo Allah destroy
her RK me GU da fiel utilises que haces
para para para para para otra vez lucky
me methanol was second yellow mucho no
[ __ ] Alamos didn't matter who they re
yellow the the fa tres tres años más o
menos al principio kiya
push consumer and michael calvess Takara
Maliki well okay Gao Gao was he a por
esto pasa Via Appia tanto stress non
sabes que no es bueno no sobre todo
cuando cuando uno esta tratando de
aprender una una lengua nueva me boy
poquito a poco de
directa multi yummy me gusta esto versus
the premier palabras de manera
imperiously heat was t so a pseudo
course of interesante para para todo el
mundo problemas que la gente sty stress
Allah no tu tiene stress stress the
aprender no tienes que aprender más bien
esta / interior ministry goes are de la
penita proposed la gente se si pero goes
ah si si si go fasta us test rosado's
nosotros Emidio my no tenemos que serán
escuela y ways so ISIL in Syria bro
tiene su su reglas Apprendi see below la
palabra el hierro poor ahem pollo no no
recuerdo mi mismo no pues buscando es
esta palabra en de Janerio poor Hempel o
las palabras como el hierro la red pues
now she said not the auto to english
when a Jewish toss-up in the route
restores new practice practice Asia LSD
Amish Assyrians who government is so
premier principal mutagens this prison
from a possible fallar muchos English
mathematician temple service linguist
problema tombe
no NOS swear up Ramirez Limbo's members
must obey practica hace una vez para
pronounce Catherine everybody upon selma
problem landed but a permanent
representative recorded :
Susan poco de fallar coca Megumi's
rapacious intelligent now now now that
you with tempura managed now play
Quentin and record the record their
periodic good for example - Oh
Bullwinkle me gusta mucho superiority
yeah I suppose as well I should release
this come conversa go to wash come on
somebody
no mood to a desk a good accent released
stamping oh gosh very simple you know
nice it seated younger to parentage all
the problem secret of it Akuma see a
bunny in all the victims silver silver
II don't see Sevastopol is pure politics
eat Castilla dijon due to social
Charlotte - decaf - Sofia of the valley
and they do not date were to disappear a
tamil dr. julie services repertoire but
not actual Patel Patel compactly it we
are committed to shirokawa Noma
Commerce's shown not near possibilities
emotional issues you prepare the tundra
was most similar tasks to her badly
lyrically showing through it was several
beaucoup de nuit
but then her Budapest you see before we
could over 80 percenter a vacuum
properly active the supermodel popular
Messiah day so for Papa to produce key
we can finish the interview finish off
with English there's another important
subject that I want to discuss with you
okay would think of the of the school
system in general youth think mister my
language learning
well do you think the language learning
can actually occur happen in in a school
in a class or do you think that we
should all be independent learners and
I'm using it's possible to change the
school system so that it can become
really efficient what do you think of
the for example this is the
we have the internet which didn't exist
20 years ago - ten years ago you know -
well I think it's going to revolutionize
language learning so what do you think
of the baton at the school system in
general and what do you think in terms
of Internet and the school system could
internet change the way students learn
mind in school well in general well
going going back to first question about
school system in general I think in
every group you certainly gonna have one
or two students who who would do
exceptionally well for example as for as
for me when I was studying in English at
school it was not outstanding but it was
not that bad either I would give it
probably on a scale on a scale from 1 to
10 I would give it probably 6 or 7 out
of 10
well midnight and in general I think
it's hard to learn languages at school
because somehow school system tastes all
the fun out of language learning so yeah
you know when you when you get to do
different exercises and quizzes this
could be discouraging - but what do you
think of them if they introduced some
kind of you know the Internet in the
school in an in school in general what
do you think if they changed completely
do you think it's possible usable before
you change the system or do you think
the system is gonna be that way well
because they're not reasons etc etc I
think it is I think internet could
definitely to facilitate the language
learning process given the fact that
let's say you have 30 students in a
class and everyone has their own
interests and if every student was given
some flexibility on uncovering the
content that he or she interested in I
think the the overall the results could
be improved dramatically
so that's what I think yeah I agree 100%
no I mean thank you very much for this
very interesting interview and possibly
hopefully we're going to do another one
which is only be heard
part which is going to touch another
topic which has two languages but it's
going to be it's going to be different
so we're going to use our languages but
to talk on different topics and
different stuff okay so thank you very
much and it'll be good yeah Luca report
on speaking I'm speaking to you next
time Luca hey take care and while you
all bye
yeah ciao